too
tni
どうぞんだボンボンボン
気が vivo
どの温泉ソムリエの武蔵です
ガラガラでありましたうん
テックス鹿児島始まりますけれども
今回
たくさんの素晴らしい方が登壇されます
僕だけが色物
しかもトップバッター
やることは決まりました
それは
茅
ということでお話しさせていただきたいと思います
僕には
好きなものがあります
なんだと思いますか
多さです
この中で温泉が好きという方どれ位いらっしゃいますか
ありがとうございます
今日の会場は暖かいですはーい
はい
僕が温泉
を好きになった子の理由というのは
a 音声のもたらすさまざまな効果にあります
音声には
物理効果と呼ばれるもの
また薬理効果と呼ばれる頃
そして転地効果と呼ばれるものがあります
この3つが重なり合い
影響し合い
複雑な力を発揮する
このシナジー効果と呼ばれるものが温泉の力です
i love 温泉
長田中ん
遅いに入る
方
月に1回温泉に入っ
入らない
このさ1.25倍の幸福度の差が出るというようなデータがあります
ぜひ皆さん
温泉に入って言って25倍の
幸福度というものを感じていただければというふうに思います
ご存知の方も多いと思いますけれども僕は鹿児島温泉観光課六三四城というホーム
ページを作っています
鹿児島温泉観光課といいますが
僕1人で行っています
社長兼平社員
現在鹿児島県の温泉を線施設以上
めぐりーホームページの方に両方を掲載しています
県内様々な音声を回り
いろんな疑問そして
感じましたん
そこで
その謎や疑問2んを解決するために近くを通ります
温泉ソムリエ
また
温泉入浴指導員
様々な資格を取りました
鹿児島県内の音声を託さしているそして本線の知識もあっあっ
ということで今現在
メディアや
執筆勝人
そういったところで仕事をさせていただきます
まあの温泉なんでもやっ
非常に
使い勝手の良い
役回りをさせていただいております
そして線施設も入りますとお金を払って入る温泉というものはもなくなります
僕のライフワーク現在
雪山
森
うんそこに湧く温泉を探す
の縁と
これが現在の僕のプライベートの活動です
さて今日は皆さんによく行くということをお話ししたいと思います
よく行くという言葉聞いたことある方どれ位いらっしゃいますか
まだ浸透していませんね
僕よく行くというものは食育とかですね
a
温泉で
学ぶという部分での授業
これをよく行くという形で僕は今させていただいています
このよく行くの原点となったのが仙台の滝後温泉というところです
僕は小さい時にここに祖母と当時に来ました
当時
ご存知ですか
麻世さん
62動き
温泉神社に散歩 o 4
そして朝ごはんは
tk 子玉子かけご飯
そして午前午後温泉に入っ
その間は昼寝
適度の運動質素な食事
そして温泉こういったものが
体をリセットしてくれる
温泉の当時というものは
湯で治すと書けますが
実際は違います
病気をしないために海保のそれが当時です
実にいい当時の形を僕は取っていたと思います
しかし子どもにとって当時というものは実につまらないものです
なぜ僕がその当時に入っていたか
それは
ここにあります
僕はここプールと呼んでいます
あとスケート所
ここで何をしていたか
温泉スイング
温泉 skating
温泉スライディング
及ぶ
走る滑るそしてがられる
昔は
いろんな地域にカミナリ親父というものがありました
そのカミナリ親父に怒られないように
オヤジがいる時は
いたずらをしない親父がいるときは悪さをしないそういった
ずるさを覚えたのもここ
滝温泉です
この竹ませんで
オヤジに教えてもらったこと
これは温泉の愛だったわけです
なぜ
今現在よく行くを始めたパパ
この写真をご覧いただければわかると思いますけれども
これは僕がこの10年間で入ってきた温泉でなくなってしまった
温菜です
鹿児島では現在1年間で10件以上の温泉がなくなります
この温泉を
なくしたくない
一つの原因は原因は利用者の減少
そして病院は様々あります
僕の大好きな温泉がなくなっていく僕に何かできないかということを考えたときにこう
いったキーワードが浮かんできました
そして僕は
よく行くというものをやろう
そのように留めます
利用者の減少を少しでも減らしたい
そこでよく行くを思い出します
このよく行くですが
僕が始めた投手
情報がほとんどありませんでした
ですので温泉ソムリエやその他の音声の資格を生かし
おもしろおかしく
よく行くの授業というものを始めました
よく行く
皆さん
聞いてみませんか
聞いてみたくないですか
若干リアクションが乏しいです
ありがとうございます
それでは僕が子供たちに行っているよく if
これからいたしたいと思いますあくまでも子どもたちに行っているものです
皆さんも汚れのない清らかな心で聴いて頂ければというふうに思います
おいすー
元気がないねもう1回おいすーっ
はいこれからね鹿児島温泉大好きおじさんのよく行くの授業を始めたいと思います
テックス鹿児島よく行く事業ということでねこれから音声のことについていろんなお話
をしていきたいとおもいまーすではですね
まず温泉温泉ってなんだろえっ
聞いた時にすぐ入って答えられる人いるかな
ん
子供代理3だねぇ
みんな子供よ分かってねー
はい温泉って何だろうってねえバカなはいっ
おっきー love のいいねぇ他に入っ
はいっ
あんたカヨホラすばらしいですねそれを全て正解です
ですが温泉実はこれ温泉法と呼ばれ米法律にしっかり書かれてあります御線香の代以上
ここに来中から湧出する温水香水水蒸気出す温度が丸バルド以上
また物質を含んでいるものという風に
開かれてあります温度なんですけれども何度くらいだと思いますか
ちょっと待てよ
何度ぐらいだと思いました何度ぐらいだと思いますか
100ぞ
暑いですねー他に
わかんないですか
30度いいところついてますねはい温度なんですけれども25度です
地面から湧き出す温度がですね25度以上あるものでオール水又は水
ちょって出すこういったねものも温泉であるティシュー後ドって遠いぐらい様と思い
ます25度
安心してください入ってます
ですねー
みんながね夏に入るが後のプール
これが出たい行きたい25度くらいなんだよねだから
に0フールに入る時にはねああこれが温存線のんだこれぐらいあったなぁということを
ね
思い出してくださいはい
次です地域にあるいろんな温泉ね
鹿児島県は温泉王国と言われていますたくさんの温泉があります
まず号れ何かねああなんだと思う
温泉の嫌いな道わかんない
なんかこれこれ何かなと思いますあの子の小さい子達
これ僕の子供と思ってください子供と一緒に入っているので
家族風呂ですね鹿児島には家族風呂があります日なぁた山
また有能素ですねこういったところは家族風呂が非常に多い
場所でございますで家族風呂っていうのはですね日本全国にあると思いますがじつは
これ南九州が発祥
鹿児島熊本で昭和40年代にねできたものが図
全国に広がっていっただからカオス家族岩稲島の宝でございますのでこれはちょっとた
県民にですね自慢していただければなというふうに思います厚木ですはいこれ何かな
これなんですかねぇ
はい今8日ですねはい鹿児島温泉大好きおじさんすごく楽しそうな顔でですね
お風呂に入っております鹿児島県内なんですけれどね
霧島桜島そして三島村十島村
こういったところには温泉こういったの混浴のですね
温泉がありますだからねみんなも大人になったらね
このようなキレイなお姉さん方とですね入っていただければなあというふうには思い
ます相次ぎ
温泉のマナーはいこれおばあちゃんが座っているところ
団第と言いますこの番台でにお金を払ったりシャワーシャンプーや席を買ったりできる
場所
優しそうなおばあちゃんですね温泉のマナーなんですけど
でもねはい
いやーやっちゃいましたね暴れん坊優しそうなおばあちゃんぴっぷり
これは通常子どもたちすぐ笑います
それで僕もだんだん乗ってくるっていう感じなんですけれども子供がすごく笑ってくれ
ますねええ
これどうしてみたねやっぱりねしっかりねたたんでロッカーとか日後にね
治すこれで鹿児島でねなおすっコレ大事よねはいえーこれ守ってください
厚木
うわぁ大もうびちゃびちゃだねぇ
もがっついてたんじゃねえ熱波になりがいてないかっ
えっ
お風呂の中お風呂場で中で肌吹いてでるこっちが大事だよね
あってもビチャビチャになるとねええ
なんかも入りたくなくなっちゃうよねあと必ず閉めるって書いてるね染めてないよねー
必ずドアを閉めるそして体をからず必ず中で拭いて出るということ
これ覚えておいてくださいそして
はいもうこれラストなんですけどね一番大事なことということは次に入る人が気持ち
よくということ
これをね考えていれば
今のような音ぬぎっぱなしとかびちゃびちゃるママとかね
a ではでないのでこれをねみんな守ってください今日お話ししたことをね
お父さんお母さんおじいちゃんばあちゃんにね教えていただければなというふうに思い
ます
ちょっとまあ
これが僕のよく行くです
ありがとうございます
あの子供は基本的に開きます
ですので45分間という限られた授業
中でいかに楽しく a
集中させるかということを念頭に置いてこのよく行くをやっています
子供の表彰
みんながこんな表情になります
ここはこの表情を見るためによく行くをやっているのかなというふうに思いますけどね
そしてあの僕のよく行くでは
温泉法の話もしましたけれども
その他にも
入浴時の志望者事故は死亡事故者数とかですね
跡温泉の科学的な効果というような大人でも知らないような話をしますですのでそこで
子どもたちが
あるスイッチが入るわけですね大人が知らないという言葉を聞いたときに子どもたちに
新しい気持ちが芽生えます
まあそれが
したい
話したい教えたいそして伝えたいという気持ちが芽生え
それを唱え伝えている
通常大人から子供へのベクトルは多いですが子供から大人へのベクトルが働き
温泉に入る習慣のない家庭であっても子供の方から温泉に行きたいというような
動きが出てくる
このよく行くのゴールがこの温泉の楽しさ
温泉の面白さを知った子供たちが
大人になった時に地域を離れ
自分の
故郷の温泉
その素晴らしさ魅力そういうのを伝えてもらう
温泉エヴァンゲリスト a 版エヴァンゲリオンとかありますよね
伝道師になっていただければなと
いうことが僕の4区域の大目標でもあります
最後になります
僕のよく行くの中で
魔法の言葉
をみなさんにお伝えして締めさせていただきたいと思います
この言葉を伝えることで
唱えることで
温泉が楽しくなり
もっと
有意義な温泉ライブを
過ごすことができると思います
同じ湯に浸かる方に
唱えてください
4かゆですね
この言葉で
温泉が楽しくそして良い時間を過ごせるようになります
遺書
温泉は楽しく
マナーを守って入浴温泉総務で刺しでしたご視聴ありがとうございまーす